docker it's probably a word you're
hearing a whole bunch right now if
you're anywhere near the computing
community well what is it first of all
it's a container and we'll just call
that a bucket
do you need like an arch linux or ubuntu
server there's a bucket for that
do you need a
server for php or golang we've got a
bucket for that
do you need a fully fledged and ready to
go wordpress website we've got a bucket
for that the second thing is it's
portable
you can take these buckets you can send
them to your friends your friends can
work on them they can send them back to
you so there's no more it works on my
computer it works on your computer
problems anymore if it works on your
bucket you send that same bucket
straight over to your friend and then
third
let's say
you and your friend are done you need a
thousand of these buckets so that
multiple people can
use them
well you can just scale them as many
many times as you want
and so that's docker in a nutshell hope
that helps